one I propose
started there's lots to do we're gonna
continue on vector space models focused
especially today on dimensionality
reduction we'll look at a whole family
of models for dimensionality reduction
and kind of try to understand what
they're doing and how they're related to
each other and so forth stepping back
for a second I was thinking that the
ideal timing for everything this week
would be that we actually finished this
slide show like midway through class on
Wednesday because what I'd love to do is
just create some space in here for
people to do hands-on work with the
notebooks or especially with the
homework because it would be wonderful
if you all left here on Wednesday
feeling like you know your system was
set up you knew what to do with the data
you kind of knew the rules of the game
you could very quickly run through the
homework problems to get thinking about
your original system that's the ideal I
do want to balance that though against
the fact that I don't want to rush and
in particular the questions from people
last time we're really wonderful they
were very perceptive and kind of pushed
us in just the right direction so I
certainly don't want you to feel like
you can't raise your hands because we're
not in fact in a rush this was just an
ideal and we have to balance these
pressures but just so you know I would
like to create some space for hands-on
problem-solving because I think that's
really rewarding and we have a lot of
the teaching team available to help you
out with exactly the problem that you
have at exactly the moment you have it
and I think that's a really great
environment for learning so that's where
we're headed a few other announcements
so we have a very accomplished teaching
team they have lots of different kinds
of expertise and so a bunch of them have
volunteered to do kind of short little
lectures or units that we sprinkled
throughout the course that I think are
going to add various things so the first
one yeah the first one comes on May 1 at
the end of our unit on natural language
inference which is our first look at
like really big supervised of labeled
data sets it was going to talk to us a
bit about lifelong learning and I'll let
him unpack that term for you but he's
done a lot of work under that rubric
that's kind of going to be giving you
some
interesting machine learning insights
and also maybe connecting with things
from cognitive science so that's nicely
timed and then a little bit later in the
term when we talk about metrics and
methods this has volunteered to think
about kind of a next phase of that where
we move beyond standard precision recall
accuracy time kinds of things and really
think in a serious way about what it
means for a system to generalize in a
useful way
on a real-world problem and kind of
introspect on what these systems are
actually learning so that'll be exciting
and that's nicely timed when we talk
about contextual word representations in
this class I am going to talk about the
models but we're going to be kind of
focused on how those models and you know
pre chain representations could be used
as tools that would improve whatever
you're doing for your project that's
going to be my pitch and as a kind of
counterpart to that is going to talk
about another very familiar thing that
might improve your systems which is just
I give you a pretty long blob of text
like a whole article or some kind of
piece of context for the problem you
want to talk about what's an effective
way to turn that big blob of text into a
fixed dimensional dense representation
that you could use for another problem
on May 22 again in the spirit of just
helping you get moving in interesting
directions on your project is going to
talk about data augmentation which is I
guess like making maximal use of the
data you have available to you and then
when you guys are thinking about
actually writing up and presenting your
work it's going to talk about new
techniques that you might use to kind of
probe what might be a black box model to
figure out what it's learning and that
could be illuminating just for you as
someone who wants to understand your own
system but also of course that's
wonderful stuff for a discussion or
error analysis section where we kind of
get a higher level insight beyond the
numbers into what your system is doing
so I'm really excited by the sequence of
things because I think this is going to
really nicely compliment the core strand
of work that we plan to talk about so
thanks to the teaching team and lots
more to come
oh and and relatedly the friday session
on python and jupiter notebooks that was
great
Thanks to everyone who part
dissipated the video and corresponding
materials Lucy link to them from Piazza
so if you missed that session but you're
fumbling around with your notebooks or
with your Python do check out that stuff
and we're also thinking of doing one
kind of a bit later in the term that
would be focused on numpy for scientific
computing that is kind of like
vectorizing your code and also pi torch
which this year we're kind of pitching
as the default choice you might make for
doing deep learning and we've got a lot
of support for that alright that's some
stuff to come a few other things that I
just wanted to mention first a bunch of
people have asked about the role of the
notebooks in my view for this year what
the notebooks do is complement the main
lecture so what we're trying to do in
here with you all is give you a guided
tour of the content and highlight some
stuff but I think the real work will
start when you open one of up one of
those notebooks follow that narrative
and whenever you don't understand
something or you have an open question
or something else you want to pursue you
use the code embedded in that notebook
to answer that question for yourself
that's the kind of hands-on learning
that I think can really push you in new
directions and that's what the notebooks
are for they're also useful if you open
up the homework notebook and feel kind
of at sea about how things work you can
bet that the actual notebooks are meant
to get you oriented and so forth so but
they're meant to play that kind of
informal role yeah you read it we have
questions so we're not we don't every
yeah that's fair I mean you must have
questions because this is complicated
stuff and you could spend a whole
lifetime meditating on any one point of
it so my pitch to you would be when you
have questions the notebook is a good
way for you to begin to answer them for
yourself and that's the primary thing
that I want it's not so much about
evaluating you or making sure that you
do a particular kind of reading or
anything but rather just empowering you
to try some new stuff and all of this is
meant to give you a head start on a
project or something like that and also
as I said on on the first day to kind of
start to try to convey to you what we
understand to be best practices for
setting up projects running experiments
dealing with data and so forth
if you are struggling with your setup
you can post on Piazza and we might be
able to help but there is some stuff
that you could do on your own that might
help with debugging and I think one
powerful way that you could kind of
check the health of your class
environment is to actually use the tests
that are embedded in the github
repository there's a subdirectory called
tests you can see from all these files
tests underscore and Li and so forth
we've got pretty good coverage across
all the core code and if you use PI test
which is installed if you use anaconda
and you type py dot test and I like to
do VV because it gives you a kind of
health dashboard and you run it on one
of these files it will run a bunch of
tests and all the tests in these
directories should pass and if they
don't you might get an error saying like
you know hey you haven't installed this
library or something and that would be
really helpful for people trying to
debug with you and also I'm just kind of
pitching this PI test is a very easy way
to write a bunch of tests you basically
just named your method the first word
should be test and then PI tests will
treat it as a test and if you look at my
code you see you can get really good
coverage really fast and one thing that
might be of utility to you is that I
have in test NP model gradients that's a
kind of gradient checking infrastructure
so if you write your own model like in
pure numpy then you could use that to
check its health essentially the health
of the back property that's it by way of
kind of semi random announcements for
the homework one I have a few things
that I wanted to clarify let's start
with easiest stuff so I hope it's
emerging by now and it's certainly going
to emerge today that PMI point-wise
mutual information is a very powerful
insight related to all this stuff not
only re waiting but also dimensionality
reduction and as a result it's a very
natural baseline if you were actually
doing a project in this space then it
would be nice if the remain results
table had a row
that was just what happens with positive
PMI or PMI because you can bet that the
fancy thing that you're actually
advocating for is in some sense related
to or complements or is in opposition to
the PMI insight and so the reason for
having that is the first homework is
just to push you to essentially fill in
the first row of that results table from
there you know you're kind of exploring
more advanced things we're going to talk
about LSA today and I'll talk about I
sort of explained to you why you might
want to check a bunch of these different
K values and why that's going to be an
issue for you in all likelihood and then
this final one is just a toe in the
water on using the glove model which
we're going to talk about today to
possibly develop some powerful vectors
and I'm hoping that having done those
first three questions and thought about
the rest of this material you've got
some ideas for your original system
which you'll enter into the bake-off
that's the overall rationale any
questions about that yeah what oh you
didn't quite go where I thought you were
going because what I thought you were
gonna say is if you give me a word by
word matrix it's kind of interpretive
what's happening because if I look
across the row at the different column
values I can see like oh this is the
strength of association in some sense
with the word amazing or the word
terrible and that's pretty interpretable
I mean we're talking about huge high
dimensional spaces so it's not like any
of us has analytic command but that's
pretty good and but then once you start
to do things like glove or LSA which
we'll talk about today the columns
become much less interpretable but you
were actually at the first point feeling
like you didn't have the intuitions is
that right
the column has like the window right and
like how one of the lengths of scaling
vary in their distance factor between
two columns I don't know I mean the
scaling thing I would separate and
separate out and I would say scaling is
you modeling your intuition about how
proximity to your focal word counts for
co-occurrence it could be that you count
them all the same or that you feel like
being farther away is less of a
co-occurrence but once you've built the
matrix you know you have this high
dimensional space and for there I always
do this but I kind of want to quote this
famous some quotation from John von
Neumann in mathematics you don't
understand things you just get used to
them and I feel like a lot of this stuff
is just about getting used to it and
I've already pitched to you that VSM
neighbors function as a way to kind of
see what's happening and comparing
across different matrices you've built
will give you intuitions and we're gonna
do some visualization stuff today that
might also help but beyond that you
might just have to reflect two points of
clarification the first one is easy I
threw into VSM data this adjective
adverb matrix which is collected from
Giga word as adverb adjective dependency
pairs which i think is a really
interesting notion of context very
different from just raw like being in
that linear window but I didn't mean for
you to have to make sure that your
bake-off entry worked for that matrix
it just won't it's a completely
different vocabulary and so forth so I
added in just a clarification that all
I'm talking about is the two IMDb ones
and the two Giga word ones don't do the
heroic thing it would take to get the
experiment code to work with that other
one that's certainly not something I
want to do to construct then more subtle
maybe more worth discussion here is I
added a note just clarifying being
trying to be really explicit that for
the bake-off you should not bring in
external vectors
like you shouldn't just download the
pre-trained glove or the pre-trained
burt or elmo or other representations
that you've heard about and enter them
into the bake-off what I'm trying to do
the spirit of this is to say start with
the count matrices that I gave you so we
all begin from like a level playing
field same spot and then do cool things
to those matrices that's the spirit of
this it gets a little complicated
because I want to encourage you to do
retrofitting so I can't say something as
clean as don't introduce any outside
information because I think retrofitting
to wordnet is a worthwhile thing to do
and I'm gonna talk about how you might
do that in a little bit so I've done
this thing of saying no external vectors
but I don't know that this is completely
the right answer I mean part of me wants
to just leave you completely unfettered
to do whatever you want beyond like
figuring out what the test set is right
you know in the real world if you'd
entered a bake-off you could do pretty
much whatever you wanted to do I'm here
I don't know this is an attempt to keep
us all on the same trajectory but I
don't know I did download Bert and Elmo
at least some small models and glove and
see how well they would do in the
bake-off and they don't they do okay but
then again I never win these bake-off so
what do I know
yeah I don't know about this you know I
don't know what the right answer is yeah
so that's what I would want to exclude
is that you would use the glove ones but
that you could use the vectors from like
giggle word or ones that you had
developed you could retrofit them that's
the spirit of this but in doing that
you'd be bringing in word net structure
and that's where I fall apart on this
idea of not introducing outside
information and that but the real battle
I'm having here is like maybe it's the
right thing to do to download Bert and
do some cool rewedding and then learn a
function that will do really really well
at this task right that could be a
scientific discovery or combining Bert
and
Elmo and representations from my
matrices that you you know massaged in
various ways maybe that's the right
answer and I'd sometimes like I don't
want you to feel constrained
artificially because what's the sense in
that on the other hand it would be kind
of sad if off-the-shelf Bert
you know everybody did it and everybody
got the same score so I don't know I
guess I'm the authority and so I've set
the rules now and we'll see what happens
for future bake-offs I don't think we
have to play this game because I think I
can more or less just say do what you
think will be interesting scientifically
and successful empirically yep matrix so
oh I didn't follow you could once you've
implemented this t-test thing here you
could run that on one of these matrices
I think that's pretty successful
actually so yeah that'll work for that
one other lonely duckling in the VSM
directory it's called I clarified down
here if you have the latest notebook you
can just read through this Giga word NYT
adds mod matrix that one is just there
for fun if you're a linguist who has
studied scaler adjectives then this is a
particularly interesting space but for
most of you it's probably just an aside
here but it has the wrong vocabulary to
enter the bake-off you'll get a whole
bunch of errors if you try to make sure
your code works with that matrix and
that's what I was worried about you all
like battling against this when really I
just meant to exclude it sure
one more thing about this notebook so
this is a small change that I pushed and
this is so strange how the mind works I
guess I woke up this morning just sure
that I had made this omission and sure
enough I had I don't know why it
occurred to me at the point that it did
but this full word similarity evaluation
the change that I made is just exposing
dissed font before it wasn't exposed and
that meant that when you called word
similarity evaluation down here it was
going to use cosine because cosine is
the default for that function and the
reason that I'm shocked that I did this
is just that I had been quietly thinking
that a really interesting source of
innovation for this bake-off
would be that people actually thought a
lot about that dist funk there because
you can use cosine or Euclidian or
jacquard but all you really need to have
in that position for this code to work
is some function that will take two
vectors and produce a real value and if
you think about it at that level there
is lots of stuff that you could do that
would kind of go beyond the methods I'm
introducing but some of you have the
background that could make that very
exciting it could be a learn function of
the data for example that you wrote
yourself and so I was sad that I had not
exposed this nothing will go wrong if
you don't use my updated version but I
kind of encourage it because that's a
point something to think about that
makes sense
good there are just a couple more
announcements that I wanted to make
again just by way of you getting you
familiar with this this is of the
repository I hope you all are working
productively in this repository I just
wanted to point out that kind of on the
back end modeling side there are three
groups of models there are these NP
prefixed ones that's for numpy those are
simple versions of the relative models
like auto encoder and classifier and so
forth but they expose everything so if
you really want to understand what's
happening under the hood when these
systems learn things from data that
would be a good place to look
but if you just want to get some
interesting work done then I would use
either the torch versions or the
tensorflow versions I had kind of plan
to just switch to torch because I think
the code is really nice and transparent
and if you want to do modifications and
so forth it's typically pretty easy and
I'm going to ask you to do some of that
later
so I recommend the torch but the
tensorflow is faster and so if you need
to get a big job done or you're just
accustomed to tensorflow then those are
there for you as well and just
conspicuously missing is the tree
version because at least as far as I can
tell it's very difficult to do neural
network models with kind of arbitrary
graphical structure in tensorflow but in
pi torch that's wonderfully transparent
and easy so that's kind of what pushed
me over the edge relatedly I thought I
would do a shout out I just pushed some
nice improvements to the PI torch code
that are thanks who was a student in
this class so thanks I also wanted to
thank the people who are helping me get
credits so we have Google Cloud credits
that's posted on Piazza and I'm working
with some of these other vendors to try
to get credits for you via them as well
alright those are that's it for
announcements and preparatory material
any questions ask me anything before we
dive in oh one more thing
I made some updates to the slideshow so
you might want to download the version
download it from the web again mostly
it's just additions but there were a
couple of Corrections I guess this will
be on the video I'm not sure if you're
taking notes and you started taking
notes on the first PDF this will help
you merge the two having this list here
but otherwise you could just download a
fresh copy one of the improvements is
this slide 26 and that's kind of where I
want to start but let me build up to
that so last time we talked about matrix
designs we talked about vector
comparison and we started in on basic
reading for vector comparison there were
kind of three big ideas
like three big comparison methods so
first was Euclidean and cosine and
though you could call those kind of like
the the classical geometric vector
comparison methods both stated as
distance measures and I introduced all
these matching coefficients I'll sorry
all these methods that are based on
matching coefficient like jacquard and
dyson overlap and then I introduced a
family of like probabilistic vector
comparison methods that seem like good
choices if you are dealing with things
that you would call probability
distributions so that was the kind of
kind of the plot of that section and I
stated some relationships and
generalizations which you can use the
code to check if you like
and this was by way of trying to make
sense of this now the other shout out
that I wanted to do is to
so you're not
chatting after class we walked back to
the department and he was very
supportive of course a very gentle guy
and I but I could tell that something
was bugging him a little bit and so we
kept talking and I kept trying to figure
out what was bugging and the one thing
that I managed to extract from him that
was clearly bugging him is that I had
called a lot of these things distance
metrics especially cosine and the way I
stated cosine distance that is not a
proper distance metric and I know this
is true I kind of knew this I had just
not made much of it but I actually liked
this as a way of additionally like
making sense of the options here so this
slide kind of summarizes the argument to
qualify as a distance metric a vector
comparison method D has to be symmetric
it has to assign zero two identical
vectors and it has to satisfy crucially
this thing called the triangle
inequality which is the distance between
X and Z has to be less than or equal to
XY to Y Z and it's called the triangle
inequality you can kind of see here like
if this is Z at the bottom x and y it's
just saying that these two things the
sum of them have to be larger than this
shortcut here right very intuitive
cosine distance as I defined it is not a
metric because it fails that triangle
inequality and you know it's very easy
to find counter examples and here's just
one random one that I found that would
show that as I defined it this is not a
distance metric there is a way to
correct that here's the definition here
I actually don't know myself why this
isn't for example the version that's in
numpy numpy uses the one that I
introduced which I think which seems to
be pervasive but this is the correct
Euclidean and if you want to think in
these terms then this could help you
make decisions because the only things
that are distance metrics of the stuff I
introduced are Euclidian Jensen Shannon
and cosine as its defined in this new
way here the things that art distance
metrics are all those matching methods
KL divergence because it's not even
symmetric
but also symmetric al is not a proper
distance metric and of course kale was
skew which is just a kind of weighting
of the reference versus the target
distribution that's just like KL it's
not a distance metric so if you find
this at this elegant as a classification
and you want to work only with proper
metrics then some of your choices become
clear if you're in a probabilistic space
use y ensign Shannon it's got all these
nice properties if you want a more
classically geometric notion use
euclidean or the corrected cosine and
the nice thing about that that I think
will emerge especially today is if your
vector space is kind of properly
normalized like for example if you did
the l2 norm of all the vectors then
Euclidean versus cosine doesn't matter
at all that's a point that I made before
and that actually I just wanted to
verify this that you can check with the
code that if I do cosine distance here I
get the exact same result if I do the l2
norm and then use aleut Euclidean as the
comparison method that was one of those
generalizations the numbers are
different but the ranks are all the same
and that's kind of like saying for what
we care about there's no difference at
that point and so that's actually kind
of clarifying from this whole mess of
things that I offered kind of web by way
of just helping you with keywords you
might encounter in the literature I
think we can distill it down to some
pretty clear guidance so thank you for
being particular about this and then
there were some code snippets here
questions before we move on that was
kind of a recap with a little bit of
bonus content to help clarify oh good we
also started talking about rewedding and
I gave the goals here which is kind of
amplify the important and D emphasize
the mundane and the quirky we covered l2
norming and probability distributions
his way to do ways to do that and then I
kind of paused here and I said observed
over expected this is a really important
idea because you see this throughout all
of these methods that I'm going to
introduce today and there's a whole mess
of math up here what it's essentially
doing
this metric here is measuring like
calculating our expectation for the
count based on the row in the column and
then comparing that to the actual
account and if our expectation is
smaller than the actual account we
should amplify that that kind of thing
there's a lot of math here and so what I
tried to do is just I I added this slide
this is a kind of intuitive example of
why this why these numbers are
interesting so I created this fake this
toy vector space here and the conceit of
this is that the word keep is incredibly
frequent it co incurs with lots of other
words so 20 20 20 and enjoy is pretty
frequent and then if you think down the
column this word tabs here my idea is
that it's idiomatically related to keep
write keep tabs as an idiom and tabs
itself it does occur outside of that
idiom but relatively infrequently and
surely because this is a kind of
collocation alidium attic expression
keep tabs should have a really high
count there that's what we would expect
because of that midia matusa T that's
the count matrix and when you count when
you go through the expected values here
this is the full calculation and then
you get these expected values you get
the result that you were hoping for in
the sense that our expected count for
keepin tabs just given the probability
of the row keep and the probability of
the column tabs is like 13 but the
actual count is 20 so it's okay it's
occurring more than we would expect
given this null hypothesis and
correspondingly tabs and enjoy occur
less often than you would expect and
that's reflected in the fact that the
actual count is 1 but our expectation is
8.5 and then all observed over expected
is doing doing is dividing the actual
count the observed count by the expected
count to kind of bring these things into
a ratio space that makes sense that's
what we hope to see yeah
very low values well I think that's kind
of the intuition that keep tabs and keep
and reading co-worker a lot because
they're both kind of frequent and it's
no surprise that they occur together and
so actually having their expected value
be just a little bit bigger than the
actual value you know that's kind of
good but keeping tabs a co-occur way
more frequently with them we would
expect given the row in the column and
that's why we're amplifying it oh well
maybe realistically it is my just a toy
example so if I had changed the numbers
I guess I could have made it higher but
this seemed pretty good to me in the
sense that 20/13 is much different than
20/20 three just in kind of an absolute
sense and that's the sense in which this
is occurring way more often than we
would expect yeah so expected is
basically what we expected everything
was independent yes and then our o is a
frequency independence frequency
independent like evaluation of how often
something happens definitely right for
the first part if you think about these
in probabilistic terms then this is a
kind of that's the the probability the
joint probability that you would expect
given that the row in the column were
independent in the probabilistic sense
for the second part I wasn't sure about
what you meant because it is dependent
on the actual frequency that's the
observed count another class of
documents do the OE for them separately
but then still take the OE that you get
from the class one and class two and
compare them without doing any scaling
sure yeah yeah yeah I just pause a
little bit just because I do want to
show you some stuff about how these OE
values scale it's maybe not ideal but
I think I think I understand your
intuition I'm inclined to agree
I believe her this point in part because
I told you that PMI was the hero of this
story and PMI is just log face observed
over expected
we're like in when you normally see this
calculation people have done what I've
done here which is first create a joint
probability table and then do the
calculations in terms of those
probabilities but all everything comes
out the same as if you do it with the
raw counts but this is a kind of basis
for the calculation and then here's the
PMI REE weighted matrix it's doing the
same fundamental thing as OE but in log
space and I highlighted these orange
values because you can see that this is
prone to exaggerating very small counts
the one over here because it's kind of
lonely in this row and this column ends
up really big in the final matrix even
though if you've worked in NLP for a
while you might think that one is
probably not so important as an event
maybe in more precise spaces this one
would be very exciting but for us it's
like a Miss tokenization or some kind of
artifact in the document I gave a few
plots here just to kind of give you a
sense for PMI values and how they scale
you could check that out on your own
this is an important extension of PMI
positive PMI this is actually the
default for VSM because it's kind of
better behaved in certain respects but
let me articulate the argument for why
you might choose this positive PMI over
a regular PMI PMI is actually undefined
when the count is 0 because I have to at
some point take the log of something
that would be zero so the question is
what to do in those situations because
we can't just leave them as infinite
values or something so the usual
response is the one that I gave above
here kind of implicitly right with log 0
equals 0 which is to map it to 0 but
so Levy and Goldberg have this nice
paper about this general class of
methods and one thing they point out is
just that this is kind of incoherent and
the argument is look for PMI larger than
expected counts get a really large PMI
and smaller than expected counts get a
really small PMI that's perfectly
intuitive but if we do this log zero
equals zero thing then the zero count
stuff gets placed in the middle of that
ranking but we don't have evidence for
it being in the middle of the ranking
like actually we just don't know that's
the point and so there's kind of
something amiss here and a response that
kind of cleans this up is just to say
that for anything that would be below
zero I map it to zero that's the sense
in which it's positive PMI makes sense
yeah lose all information yes just to
repeat that because I can't disagree
you're losing a lot of information about
all those negative values I do this a
lot especially in this unit it's an
empirical question which behaves better
I am going to give you try to give you
some guidance around this because
obviously you're doing something pretty
serious to the underlying distribution
of values and that could give you some
analytic guidance about whether this is
the right choice or not but
fundamentally I have to agree yeah if it
was just exactly the same so for o over
E if it was just exactly the same as the
actual account then it would be zero in
the log space
then that would be kind of like saying
this is exactly what we expected let me
introduce a couple of more and then
we'll step back another famous rewriting
scheme that draws on slightly different
notions of Rho in context is tf-idf this
is like famous from information
retrieval it's defined in terms of two
things so first term frequency which you
would get in are vector spaces by
dividing everything in the I don't want
to get this backwards so you would
normalize column wise if you think row
wise right so you would be getting
column wise term frequency for each one
of these columns or documents and then
the inverse document frequency is
essentially counting up how many columns
that term appears in and so what that
what the calculation is essentially
doing is amplifying the values for
things that occur in very few documents
and then the tf-idf is the product of
these two so the intuition is that
you're going to get really high tf-idf
values for cells that have very high
probability for your document that is
there like over-represented along that
column and occur in very few documents
that is traveling along the row because
that's like saying that that term is
really specially associated with that
document over represented in it and
unusual in appearing in it at all let's
say it's those two intuitions here's an
example of the calculations just to make
it really concrete you can do the IDF
values and the TF values and then you
just take their product to get the full
related matrix and again I have some
plots that kind of show you how these
values tend to scale so for example
setting aside the zero case which is
always a problem in these log models as
I get larger and as I occur in more
documents that's along this x-axis the
IDF values go down and like the epitome
of a high IDF value is to occur in just
one document because then it's like
really specially associated with that
one
document and if it has high frequency in
that document than its tf-idf value is
going to be really really large yep well
technically you can nothing would stop
you it's perfectly defined however it
can be really problematic to use these
very dense matrices with tf-idf they are
really kind of expecting a lot of
sparsity and in fact if you have a word
that appears in every document which can
that is that it occurs with every other
word like a stop word then these tf-idf
values can get completely ridiculous or
even be undefined yeah oh I was kind of
hoping you'd discover that for
yourselves but now I've given that away
well it'll save you some time but for a
very sparse word by document for example
this is proven time and again to be a
really powerful REE weighting scheme and
a powerful way to find documents for a
given query that are really like highly
associated with that query and here are
a few others t-test is when you're
implementing and I like that one just
because if you stare at this long enough
you can see that this is a kind of PMI
intuition as well there are lots of
tf-idf variants and then another one
that I could just throw out there is I
could create a pairwise distance matrix
and that might be an interesting rear
weighting scheme where like all of these
values in here are the cosine distances
between the various elements let's step
back for a second I gave you last time a
little bit of a framework for thinking
about how what these rear weighting
schemes are doing you know things you
might ask yourself as you're making
these choices and one of them was just
that you should look at the distribution
of cell values that result from doing
the relating scheme and think about what
that might mean for your problem and
here I've kind of mapped that out for
the ones that we've looked at so up here
these are the raw counts and they're
actually like you can see that there
shaped like this it's actually much
worse than this plot appears because I
did the log scale for the y axis
otherwise it looked like everything was
just at one and then you know a long
tail of things so that's a really
strange you know zipfian or log log
distribution it's kind of hard to deal
with for lots of methods and then we can
look at what happens when we take that
that incoming distribution and change it
in various ways so for example the l2
norm has more of a u-shape probabilities
are kind of similar although I confess
that I don't have a firm grip on why it
has this kind of hump before dropping
off here observed over expected values
have a similar distribution to the raw
counts so that's maybe not so good
because even though we're amplifying
some stuff it's kind of like the
underlying statistical problem remains
PMI this is a kind of friendly picture
because it looks quite normally
distributed that's pretty good
PAP mi does the thing of just chopping
off the left half and amplifying all the
zeroes but it's still not as
scary-looking as for example the raw
counts and then tf-idf looks a lot like
ppm i one more thing before I take
questions is just that beyond just
staring at these distributions you can
also I know it's hard to read but you
can look along the x-axis at the actual
cell values so of course for the counts
it goes from zero to hundred thousand or
whatever for these word word matrices
whereas the l2 norm of course is zero to
one the probabilities of zero to one
observed over expected that's kind of
constrained in a space like so even
though it looks like a scary
distribution the x axis is much tighter
for PMI and P PMI it's like here minus
10 to about 20 so not as normalized as
probabilities or l2 norms but at least
constrained and then the tf-idf values
have a similar kind of 0 to or you know
small value to 3 or something like that
and the reason I emphasize that is just
that if you think
taking distance measurements in these
spaces we've seen how sensitive some
methods are to the magnitude of these
values and this is giving you a picture
of how much that choice about distance
is going to matter for these various
spaces sorry there's a question did you
ever use distribution well for the
probabilities I just mean that I row
normalized using that scheme and then I
just looked at all the values in that
entire matrix that's what I did for all
of these in fact this is just a
histogram of all the cell values think
of them as just one long vector another
pitch I made to you is that you might
think about how the co-occurrence counts
relate to the reweighed counts so
obviously for example if you're awaiting
scheme just makes a proportional shift
of the underlying counts it's probably
not so meaningful what we really want
presumably is to see something really
different when we look at the new cell
values and how they correlate with the
old ones and so here are some plots that
do that these plots are a little bit
harder to understand but like up here l2
norming so along the x-axis these are
the co-occurrence counts that is the raw
cell values although I did the log scale
to make it easier to see what's
happening and these are the related
values and you can see it's a very
different distribution of values and the
correlation here which I've given up at
the top is pretty low so it's high it's
not that I can make sense of this space
per se but rather at least I know it's
different from the underlying count so I
did something meaningful same thing with
the l2 observed over expected the
correlation is kind of strange I
actually don't know what these artifacts
are with these kind of shocks of
correlated values but it looks like PMI
that's really nice right there's
essentially no correlation between the
underlying counts and the related values
so we did something ppm I actually has a
pretty high correlation of all of these
it's the one that's
that by this measure the least different
from the underlying counts make sense
I'll let you stare at these and try to
make sense of the amount on your own I
actually don't understand completely why
they have the particular shapes that
they do but I'm reassured that something
is happening when I reweighed are we
looking for well one of them like is it
the smaller correlations the better no I
wouldn't say that I can't go so far as
to say better I can just say that at
least I know I did something but it
really depends on how much you think the
underlying counts were important to
retain which kind of relates to whether
or not you think frequency is
information that you want to preserve in
your model here are a bunch of
generalizations just by way of wrapping
up this is this unit here so a theme of
all of this as I've said before is that
we want a way to sell value relative to
the value we would expect given its row
and it's column I think that runs
through all these schemes many weighting
schemes end up favoring rare events that
may not be trustworthy so you have to
kind of watch out and you might want to
smooth that out the magnitude of counts
can be important right so one in 10 and
1000 and 10,000 might be very different
situations in terms of language data but
for example if you take a probability
distribution they will look identical
PMI and its variants will amplify the
values of counts that are tiny relative
to their rows in the call and columns
and that can be a problem something to
watch out for and then related to the
question from the back there tf-idf
severely punishes words that appear in
many documents so it will behave oddly
for our dense matrices which are word by
word and then I offered a few code
snippets here again all of this is in
the notebooks all of this is relevant
for the homeworks but I just thought it
might be nice to consolidate it here and
show for example you can do observed
over expected
you can length normalize PMI within with
positive and tf-idf and just to show you
that we're making some progress at the
end of class last time I showed you the
neighbors of the word bad in the raw
IMDB five matrix so tight window highly
scaled and it looks terrible it's highly
collocation 'el and then there's a
period and then taste and then guy again
when I do ppm I on that same space then
the neighbors of bad are good awful
terrible and horrible and that looks
like progress right we're in a coherent
semantic space terrible and horrible
seem like they should be near bad even
though they have different frequencies
and then you might just worry that good
is in there maybe that's the problem
that you kind of want to qualitatively
solve because you have what looks like a
sentiment confusion and those being so
close I have a short section in here on
springing and sub word information this
is a newer idea and I just wanted to
make you aware of it and show you some
code that will allow you to do it this
idea in my mind at least traces to a
seminal paper by Henrik shih-tzu who
showed that if you did some sub word
modeling you could kind of overcome some
sparsity problems and also find
different and more abstract connections
between words that might turn on their
morphological analysis for example
yeah I've said that below here sub word
modelling will pull morphological
variants closer together right you might
find yourself seeing abstract
connections between all the adjectives
that end in Abel in a way that you
wouldn't if you just looked at the words
as kind of atomic units it can
facilitate the modeling of out of
vocabulary items because if you don't
have a representation for a word you can
retreat to using its sub parts which are
probably highly represented and it can
also reduce the importance of any
particular tokenization scheme which is
nice because tokenization and NLP is
this hard a priori thing that you do
before you start solving your problem
that often has huge downstream
consequences for you for the models that
you build so it's nice that we can find
ways to make that less of a major choice
and what I did here is just sketch a
technique for doing that using the data
that we have I'll just walk through the
method quickly and if they're questions
feel free to ask given a word level VSM
like the ones we've been working with
you can say that the vector for a
character level Engram X is the sum of
all the vectors of words containing X so
it's like you've gone down into the word
and treated all of those things as
co-occurring and then you can represent
each word as the sum of its character
level engrams
that's the sense in which you could
gather strength from all the parts and
then I think this is a nice touch if you
have a representation for the actual
word bring that in as well and then
maybe just like sum up all these vectors
and now you've done some sub word
modeling and brought in a whole lot of
information from different parts of your
corpus that would have been completely
neglected if you hadn't gone down to the
sub words and here I just gave an
example of how you might decompose the
word superbly into its four grams and
the only thing that's worth pointing out
there is I do think it's valuable to
have this notion of start and end
context which I've signaled with the W
here and then it's just a code snippet
so I just wrote a few utility functions
that will allow you to create an Engram
space for any end that you choose and
then this like character level rep here
it's just a small function that I wrote
that prevent presents one way of mapping
a word into its sub word model and I
just showed at the bottom here that even
though superbly as a word is not in the
vector space I can now get a
representation of it because all its sub
parts or at least most of them are in
the corpus and this is kind of
interesting if you look at how that
vector superbly relates to other words
you see some stuff that's good and some
stuff that might worry you like now it's
very close to super and other like add
like adverbs that end in ly and that
might be might be over emphasizing the
sub word information but in general I
think if I think back to the Bake off's
last year sub we're modeling was often
an important step for the top systems
make sense from yeah go ahead use upward
moment in the same you can't quite do
the same vs em that's why you have to
create this IMDB 5 engrams
and it has different dimensionalities
right all hours have dimension 5 K by 5
K but this one because there are more
engrams has almost 10 K by 5 K that's
just a design decision so that we can
use the original count matrices and kind
of find all this sub word structure in
them because we we keep the notion of
co-occurrence context the same on the
approach that I've sketched yeah
compared to like just stemming your
documents beforehand
I think stemming would be really
different right so stemming would be
like oppose because there you would be
saying that I'm going to get rid of a
lot of this morphological stuff at the
end whereas here you might be saying I'm
going to find the way in which superb
Lee is related to all these other
adverbs by the fact that they end in ly
another quick unit here I'm not going to
spend too much time on this but I think
this can be really valuable for doing
exploration just some fast visualization
techniques let me state the goals our
goal is to visualize very high
dimensional spaces in two or three
dimensions so that we can understand
them and you just have to accept upfront
that this is going to involve a bunch of
compromises there's not going to be a
system of mapping from this high
dimensional space into 2d that preserves
all that structure unless in fact your
original matrix had very little
structure to begin with right so we have
to have some compromises and but I my
pitch to you would be that visualization
can still be great because it can give
you a feel for what's in your BSM and it
can be especially nice to pair this with
some kind of qualitative investigations
using the neighbors function I feel like
with a holistic picture that's
approximate and some sampling with
neighbors you can get a feel for whether
your matrix contains what you want it to
contain and whether it has promise even
despite all these compromises
I'm flagging for you there are lots of
techniques for doing this and that in
fact in recent years scikit-learn has
added a bunch of them and they have a
wonderful user guide so I would think if
you want to go beyond the one I'm gonna
show you check out scikit-learn and see
what what they can do and they talk a
lot about the trade-offs for various
methods but what I've included in BSM is
a little wrapper around psyche it's
implementation of to see I'm not
actually sure whether I'm saying that
right but I've been saying it for years
it stands for T distributed stochastic
neighbor embedding and I would say
intuitively what this algorithm is
trying to do is go from a very high
dimensional space do dimensionality
reduction in a way that you can lay
things out in a few dimensions while
preserving a lot of local structure this
is a two Sneap lot of giga v that matrix
after i did peep sorry giga 20 after I
did positive point wise mutual
information on it and I would just say
that this looks pretty good to me
yeah actually at this point I think this
is quite beautiful you might come to
also find these things quite beautiful
because it looks like a giant blob but
actually there's a lot of local
structure and it's that local structure
that I think to sneak and capture pretty
well and that is telling me that there's
kind of neighborhoods of coherence which
is what I expect from this very high
dimensional space that I would find some
dense neighborhoods that are interesting
so that's what you can see and I
actually so here are two examples this
is the cooking one it's probably too
small to read but it's lots of stuff
about cooking and over here this is lots
of stuff about conflict terrorism war
politics and so forth but it's really
semantically coherent which is nice and
then I did the same thing this is IMDB
20 with ppm I again pretty good local
structure in here here's a positive
section this is lots of positive words
and then negative ones and I would say
this is nice because not only is there
pretty good preservation of sentiment in
this space but also you if you look
beyond the adjectives you can see that
when people talk about positive and
things they talk about somewhat
different aspects of these movies so for
example they complain a lot about the
dialogue but they talk they say lots of
nice things about actors and their
appearances and so forth so kind of one
layer beyond just raw sentiment and then
here's a little bit of code for using
the rapper that I wrote it's really
straightforward and the only nice add-on
that I want to mention is that the
function which is called to Steve is if
you give it a vector of colors which you
can set up however you want as long as
it's aligned with your vocabulary then
it will display the words in those
colors and for this example here I just
downloaded this sentiment lexicon and
then displayed all the positive words in
blue and negative in red and that can be
kind of nice to see for something that
you expect to align with your cement the
semantics of your space how well is it
actually aligning right surely I hope
that I'll see lots of blue clusters and
lots of red clusters amongst all the
grey yeah to the visualization like this
like you need a lever can you interpret
like where the clusters are in relation
to one another I think not I think
that's where this starts to break down
certainly you can't trust anything about
position on the plane in an absolute
sense because as you rerun to steel see
rotations of approximately the same
space but I think correct me if I'm
wrong but I think it is not meaningful
that like whatever blob this is is kind
of close to whatever blob this is I
think that kind of influence is getting
dispersed pretty fast throughout this
visual visualization that accord with
the understanding
that's why I tend to zoom in on local
structure excellent final phase that we
want to do here is dimensionality
reduction I'm going to present to you a
few intuitive methods for doing this and
try to give you a sense for why you
might pick one over the other we're
going to start with the classic which is
a matrix factorization method called
latent semantic analysis it's also
called truncated SVD for singular value
decomposition that's really the
underlying algorithm this is one of the
oldest and most widely used reduction
techniques and I would say that it is a
standard baseline and often very tough
to beat this is a powerful method and if
you think about building up a table of
results then this may be the second row
beyond just raw PMI I am NOT gonna walk
through the full algorithm with you
because in my experience this is kind of
the culmination of a class in linear
algebra takes a long time to build up
the relevant concepts here but I think
even if we don't do that I can give you
a sense for why this works and why you
might want to apply it so let's start
with those guiding intuitions thinking
just in 2d I've got these points a B D C
and you're probably accustomed to doing
something like fitting a linear
regression to those points so that's
that orange line there and by definition
that linear regression is going to find
this the source of largest variation
among those dots and fit a line through
them and then one thing you can do is
think of that model as saying that B its
fitted value is on this line right here
and C its fitted value is on this line
right here so you lose one dimension of
variation for the sake of this linear
model and notice what happens if you do
that if you do that mental projection of
pulling B down and pulling C up now
they're very close together that's the
sense in which have I've abstracted away
from one dimension of
variation and found an abstract
connection between these points they
were modeled in a similar way I actually
find that this is even easier to think
about if you go 3d so think about the
Stanford campus it's very flat its main
source of variation is kind of XY let's
say on the plane but it does have some
tall buildings so if you are standing at
the base of the Hoover Tower let's say
I'm at the base and Bill is at the top
we're far apart because the Hoover tower
is pretty tall but if I decide to
abstract away from this vertical
dimension I decide I'm just gonna look
at the plane then bill will be pulled
down and he'll be right next to me
that's the sense in which we're doing
dimensionality reduction we're taking
something in 3d smashing it down into 2d
and when we do that we find a connection
that was kind of missing from the
original space it makes sense the method
is singular value decomposition and kind
of the fundamental theorem here is that
for any matrix M by n I can do a
decomposition into three matrices T
which you could think of as like the row
rotation or the row matrix some singular
values lists the diagonal and a kind of
column rotation or a column matrix
that's over here and the idea is that
this the combination of these three
matrices equals this one so at the level
of the full decomposition I haven't done
anything right I've just shown you a
decomposition of the original matrix
where this gets interesting is when we
start to think about doing reduced
dimensional versions of it where we're
going to approximate the full matrix by
some sub parts of the decomposition let
me try to motivate that so here's my
example that I like this is a little
vector space of adjectives the conceit
of my example which I think is still
pretty true is that gnarly as an
adjective is a westcoast thing whereas
wicked is kind of like it's
part on the East Coast if you're from
Boston you stay with it and if you're
from Los Angeles you say darling if this
is not true anymore that's a little
embarrassing because I'm the linguist
here but set that aside I think it's
kind of kind of make sense the issue
there is that gnarly and wicked are both
positive but because of this dialect
splits they're unlikely to co-occur in
any document rather what will happen is
that they'll have neighbors in common so
gnarly and wicked we'll both tend to
over occur with awesome because that's
like across the world and across the
country anyway and not tend to occur
with lame and terrible because their
sentiment opposed but if I just use the
methods that I've showed you so far and
I calculate distance in this little
matrix here gnarly and Wiccan are really
far apart and the reason they're really
far apart is again think back to my
campus metaphor there they're not
abstractly anywhere near each other
because they never co-occurs what we
want is a kind of second-order notion of
current co-occurrence that's taking into
account the other things that they vary
with and to get at that notion we have
to do some work here's the singular
value decomposition term singular values
and document but what I've done here
this is the truncated part I'm gonna
look at just the top two dimensions the
algorithm ensures that these singular
values are organized by their size and
that correspondingly these columns are
organized by kind of the amount of
information that they contain so when I
do the approximate reconstruction using
just the two columns here I get this new
vector space reduced dimensional and in
that new vector space gnarly and wicked
are really close to each other because
the method has found this abstract
notion of co-occurrence second-order
co-occurrence you might call it make
sense yeah it's very similar yeah in
fact I do want to point out that the
there's a whole family of these methods
that you could think about and they're
all drawing on essentially the same
intuition and they just kind of play out
it's slightly different
I picked LSA because it's like the
classic for this space sell value
comparisons right I'm pitching this as a
way of understanding what happened to
the space at a high level here are the
raw counts if I just apply LSA directly
I get kind of this funny distribution
here and I think that's because LSA is a
fundamentally a least-squares method is
not so well matched to the zipfian
distribution of counts coming in over
here so if I first reweighed it by PMI
which I showed you has this kind of nice
normal distribution then the resulting
values for LSA also have a similar
distribution over here they're slightly
differently scaled and they're different
values but it's kind of more tractable
looking one more note about this so when
you read about truncated SVD or LSA the
the question comes up of how you would
pick the dimensionality K in the sense
of like I picked two here but you're
working with matrices that have 5000
dimensions how will you pick the number
of singular values that you want to pay
attention to the dream scenario that you
read about is that when you plot the
singular values by their rank you see a
bunch of high values and that a really
rapid drop-off and if you saw that you
would say oh good I'm going to pick 20
as my dimensionality because I have such
a clear fall-off in information value
from there in my experience this never
happens my distribution of singular
values tend to look like this this is
actually from one of the matrices and I
just feel like I have no idea which
value of K to pick because there's this
kind of quick thing and then a smooth
drop-off all the way to the end and
that's why as you can see from the
homework this emerges as a kind of
heuristic empirical issue of maybe
trying a bunch of different values of K
and seeing which one gives you the gain
you were looking for on the test that
you're actually trying to solve if you
ever see one of these dream scenarios do
post it on Piazza we could like have a
wall of fame for them but probably it'll
be mostly this wall of confusion
and as I said here a bunch of other
methods and a lot of them are
implemented in scikit-learn in its
decomposition and manifold packages
questions or comments before I move on
to another method there are some LSA
code snippets I think this is really
easy they're just there for reference
let's move on to autoencoders this is a
first deep learning model I guess so
auto encoders are flexible deep learning
architectures for learning reduced
dimensional representations right that's
the name of the game here it's a nice
reference let me give you the intuition
for an autoencoder the incoming examples
could be for example the five thousand
dimensional rows from one of the count
matrices that you guys are working with
the idea is that I'll take that really
high dimensional thing and pass it
through this very narrow layer in orange
maybe that has dimension 100 or 50 or 10
or whatever when you pick the job of the
autoencoder is to do its best to
reconstruct the input so you pass it
through this narrow pipe and then try to
reproduce it of course you expect given
a complex enough incoming matrix to have
some information loss but we also had
information loss with LSA the hope of
the auto encoder is that it will learn
to lose the information that's not so
important and preserve the sources of
variation that really matter and that's
the sense in which you'll get a powerful
intermediate representation so when we
run an autoencoder we train it against
this reconstruction objective but we're
at what we're actually interested in is
you know this hidden value here or one
of the hidden values if you've decided
to put a lot in the middle there I will
say that it can be hard to make it work
with that raw 5,000 dimensional vector
coming in so people do things that are
outside the auto encoder to reduce the
dimensionality so for example you might
first run LSA and kind of do a hard
external external dimension
reduction and then feed that through
your network and try to reconstruct it
to do a further layer of dimensionality
reduction for the second panel here I
thought it would be nice to just show
you everything you need if you wanted to
implement this auto encoder from scratch
the forward pass would go up and the
notation is all here and then this shows
you how to calculate the gradients and I
used exactly the notation from the numpy
implementation that's included with the
course repo in case you want to really
go down and see what the computations
are like but it's a pretty
straightforward model compress the
information and hope that it works out
for the best yeah layer here would be
what we use I would say in the homework
to predict word pairs yes and my auto
encoder is the fit method returns that
matrix of hidden representations so that
it kind of acts like well let's just say
there's lots of possibilities it will
depend on what you do but the the sharp
answer is if you feed in raw counts the
model will try to reproduce the raw
counts if you feed in the LSA
representation it will try to reproduce
that other mixtures would be different
and not maybe not standard auto-encoders
yeah it would if you have the hidden
dimensions the same as the input and
output you would hope it would learn to
just copy but since you're forcing it to
pass it through this narrow pipe it has
to lose some information or at least
represent it very differently sure and
here's some code for doing this the
interfaces are maybe a little bit
non-standard and I I tried a few
different things here in particular I
guess here I tried to length normalize
the inputs so it didn't get raw counts
coming in because I think that's a very
difficult learning problem for a deep
learning architect
sure to have raw counts coming in and it
works pretty well I think you need to
run it for longer than I did but it's
definitely on the right track
to doing something interesting oh yeah
here's a little bit of proof of that
finance in Giga five raw counts that
does not look good the auto encoder
looks much better right so that's the
raw auto encoder and here I got a little
fancy Iran ppm I and then LSA was
dimension 100 and fed that into the auto
encoder and it's at least different I
don't know how to evaluate the the - I
guess that's what the homework is all
about any questions about that this is
great timing then let me introduce one
more model just quickly and then we'll
circle back to it I think this is my
favorite of all of these dimensionality
reduction techniques for a few reasons
so this is glove global vectors you
might have heard about it it was
developed here at Stanford by Jeffery
Pennington and Richard Souter and Chris
Manning this is the paper and I guess I
want to say right at the outset as I
kind of met a comment this is a lovely
paper highly recommend that you read it
not only for the content but also just
for to experience a really well-written
well-motivated paper in our space not
all of them are but this is a kind of
exemplar they really nicely articulate
the high level goals they kind of place
you in the context that you're in right
now which is that like we have these
matrix factorization methods we have
things like PMI we have word to Veck
let's think about their strengths and
weaknesses and then let's really think
about what we are trying to do when we
build word vectors and from there over
like Section two they build up this
model very carefully and then of course
it had great experiments and they
release code and they released these
lots of pre-trained word vectors which
the community has benefited from in lots
of ways
so it's like the complete package of
what you'd be looking for in a
contribution roughly speaking the
objective for glove is to learn vectors
forward
such that their dot product is
proportional to the probability of their
co-occurrence keep that in mind because
that might already sound to you like PMI
in terms of practical details we're
using the implementation in the mittens
package which I wrote with Nik Dingwall
it's called mittens because we have a
variant of glove
it's glove with a warm start and we take
mittens to be warmer than gloves and it
should also be fast because we found a
way to vectorize glove so I would use
that for modest jobs and for really big
things you should use the glove team CMM
and implementation which is also an
impressive engineering feat and works
extremely well let me do this one slide
for you maybe two and then we'll wrap up
for the day but I would like to just
plant the seed for this so at the top
here this is the glove objective you can
see that you have a two words I and K
those are the vectors that we're
learning we're going to take their dot
product that's an idea that you've seen
before because if you think back to
cosine distance the similarity part is
the dot product over the normalization
constant there so this is kind of like
unnormalized cosine similarity there are
two bias terms and the idea is that
that's equal to the log of the
co-occurrence count for i and k they
kind of unpack that a little bit so they
define this dot product here as the log
of the probability of co-occurrence and
they define that as the log of the
co-occurrence minus the row probability
and the reason that they subtract only
the row log probability is because
they're assuming at this stage what they
call the exchange symmetry which is that
in the matrix the rows and the columns
are the same because they assume they're
dealing with a word-by-word matrix it
certainly needs to be a square matrix
for glove to work if you allow that the
rows and the columns might be different
and in fact they construct matrices
where the rows and the columns are
different and you might do that as well
then you would want to factor in the
column probability and that's what I've
down here so now you have the log of the
co-occurrence minus the log of the
product of the row and the column
probabilities and that is something that
you've seen before that is PMI right
just by the equivalence of the given
down here that's quite quite interesting
right the they give this lovely argument
that sounds like it's in a different
place from PMI and they end up back at
the PMI place now it's not literally PMI
because you have to remember that what
glove is doing is learning reduced
dimensional representations right it's
doing relating and dimensionality
reduction all at once but it is
certainly and you can see this objective
drawing on the same insight as PMI and
that's the sense in which this is kind
of the hero of our story there's a few
other things that are really meaningful
so I don't want to minimize them because
this is kind of the ideal objective and
then the actual objective is a weighted
version of it and we should talk about
why they chose the weighting scheme that
they did but just in the interest of
this having been a lot of content I
propose that we wrap up here maybe read
the glove paper think about that slide
and then we'll pick up there and move
through on into retrofitting next time